yeah it's called a plan
yeah you had a plan with fogel's sister
dude you tell brenda two ideas that are
gonna happen in the same day and he's
like that's insane
like that's a plan you delinquent chin
you've been this i feel like chin would
be a little stiff at the strip
no don't use chen as a get out of jail
free card every time we rip into brendan
nude he's like
[Laughter]
back off my broccolini
donuts and cat's the only one enjoying
them damn something grateful [ __ ]
he's got a donut right there he hasn't
tried it yet and then chin walks things
oh you know i don't
i don't eat donuts i don't eat sweets
i don't like sweets for some reason no i
don't eat donuts god damn it
a ninja doesn't donut man
ninja only does a donut in a mazda rx7
everybody know that
yeah real good donut chin likes
real donuts [ __ ] gtr on it i could
see a asian
fella or woman no offense if anybody's
you know something but um having
actual donuts on their car you know
i'd do it getting tires that look like
actual donuts you know
donuts and putting them on the side of
the vehicle putting them on the vehicle
and doing donuts yeah and spitting
throwing donuts out the back
i want mine a donut food truck dude put
your little scarf back on dude nah i'm
sick of that [ __ ] dog you really match
my outfit either you look like the
freaking
you look like the cleanup batter for the
damn uh
a league of their own that's just
the way you're dressed bring it in we're
bringing it early
you look like andy dick's personal
trainer
oh yeah that's true dude right you look
like a [ __ ] clean-up batter for the
racing bells dude what's going on here
let's get big dorothy in
let's get big door at the end dog
speaking of cleanup batters
oh dude this me throwing that junk at my
son he acted all
fresh dog i'm wondering why my pants are
off
yeah what is going on my other my other
son boston the
seven month old threw up on him and i
went well we ain't stopping because i'm
throwing this junk to this four-year-old
dang what'd you throw i threw a baseball
and he hit a goddamn home run
now i think uh i got to be honest i
think he's juicing
yeah i ain't talking about capri's son
here really no sir
i think he's juicing oh right oh yeah
he's been emailing me about some drugs
trying to slide under the radar play
that again let me see that again
so i want to be shocked what i was going
to see your picture that was a knuckle
ball
oh no underhand knuckle ball dude that
was a nut ball to either
jump faces straight at yeah my dick is
all up in the camera
boom but why do that your kid just came
out of your penis four years ago
and now you're showing him where he's
that's like showing him his home who's
this little
thick nugget it reminded me of this kid
this is alfred uh deleo delhi
this is alfred d'alia
zamar too looks shiesty dude this is sam
witch lot
god damn this little fella stick bruh
i don't
[Laughter]
if your son's hotter than your wife you
put a thong on
put his little ass in a little meat
hammock
let everybody know what he's working
with yeah yeah throw him in a freaking
nice pair of undies in a larry bird
jersey bro oh
snaps be a talk of the town let people
know he's wilding
my name is alfred d'alia at home they
call me big hal
and i have dangers there you go they
call me big ass
big al hitting them dingers big al at
that age yeah
big al hitting them arteries bro if they
call you
big ass big al hitting them [ __ ]
tortino pizza rolls that's what he's hit
dude they're going to call him
funeral before long dawg
dude obesity doesn't age well you know
it sure does
it doesn't really age does it no it just
gets locked in i mean that
that guy is thick for that age you know
big out playing that summer
baseball because you know his big-ass
thing you'll be at the pool because if
he is he's wearing a t-shirt
dude no that guy's got too much
confidence to wear a t-shirt
that's true that guy's going to be a
video vixen in atlanta by the time he's
picking up
14. no doubt back that ass
he's about that magic city he's getting
them wings i think that's the only strip
club he's going to go to
oh dude he definitely well now they got
those new strip clubs by the side of the
road you know
and you just drive by the drive-bys the
drive-thru yeah yeah the drive-through
and the trick to shake it and you like
throw money out your window wait what
yeah you never seen these you actually
don't even open the window you just
venmo from your car
yeah pretty wild bummer it's a new stuff
man get out there
okay look at this
and drive that [ __ ] into a damn car
wash they got no i need a car
because that's the thing and what
apparently what they did they all
hollowed out a car wash and put women in
there instead of washing stuff brilliant
see i need a car to do that yeah yeah
but get that uber okay
surprise the guy
surprise the guy or the lesbian are you
talking about lou williams
he left the quarantine for a funeral for
his grandfather but decided to stop at
magic city strip club and get
some wings what an idiot yeah they got
wings
or he's awesome dude danger in the whole
nba
so you can get a wing you're not really
dangerous because now you got a
quarantine so now
the joke's on him because now he's going
to miss out on 100 oh yeah that's true
and he's not going to be around
anybody it is pretty savage then i guess
yeah it's pretty dope but
the dumb thing is he gets there right
and they have wings named after him have
you heard of magic city in atlanta
no what no what is it
come
[Music]
you name a library somewhere this dude's
been
in there you know what you've been to a
strip club theo oh yeah i've been to a
couple man
man him dude first one first looks like
you look like you bring
muffins to the strip club
bro let us see that fluff who wants this
blueberry who wants them hard tops
dude but the first strip club i ever
went to was in uh
louisville kentucky with my buddy lance
hecker and he's a
i think he's like a colonel or something
in the army but
um i know he's a colonel in the navy i
bet there's some
ostriches on that [ __ ] dude he i was
too young to go in he went in
and then he would come out and tell me
what he was seeing dude
yes her stomach's a little loose but
whatever man and then like the third
time he came out i had my shirt off
he's like what the hell is going on you
start throwing money at him
yeah dude it was funny i'm not the
biggest
strip club fan are you what i don't like
about strip clubs is it seems like
somebody in there always is trying to
do something there's something bad going
like somebody's gonna steal something
from you
yeah well the girls are always it's like
always a hustle like it's always a scam
yeah my name is cinnamon yeah well just
can you just give me a re like somewhat
of a real my name is paprika my name is
bailey
yeah it's always like it's like oregano
just off the bat that's the best fake
name you come up with yeah they won
mary sarah and annie and a lot of girls
too like by me when i was growing up
they had a um
you know a strip and center they called
it basically and uh
like a college uh it was attached to
like the place where you learned to cut
hair right if
that didn't work out you went to the
back and learn to dance if you're a
baddie couldn't cut them
bangs you go next door and shake that
thing yeah yeah that's it
okay i like that bangs and things
i think that was the name of the joint
that's a good joint for a chicken wing
club
but no dude quit naming [ __ ] that's food
places dude
i'm sorry the whole thing yeah i know
non-stop you know
um but here's the thing so you go in
there and you learn to dance they teach
the ladies to dance in there you know
you got to put
leave your scissors at the door though
yeah and uh but the stage was too high
you know the stage and the ceiling of
the place was low
so you'd have to duck down and like
learn a strip at the same time you know
get your twerk so it kind of had that
michael jackson thriller oh i like that
get your eagle on
so you just could stand up a stripper
could stand up you know
but there was only about four feet of
height between the stage and the ceiling
so you had to duck down and strip that
sounds dope you know what you know what
low yeah logan oh there we go where's
that guy
where's that guy where's that guy
come on get low come on
you know what state has the most uh
strip clubs per kappa i know
nick definitely knows looks like this
one yeah
yeah do you know do i know i don't care
oh wait
that's what i just realized uh portland
portland
yeah oh really portland buncha pasty
tatted up hipster white oh with him
with them heads out dang and they're
all over dude oh you're an idiot dude
i went to a mexican place i went to a
mexican place i forgot about
that we were there i was like i'm gonna
go to the bathroom i go to the bathroom
i take a right instead of a left
i'm in a [ __ ] strip club in my hands
this is a mexican restaurant and they
had
a strip club in the back in the bed
where like if you go to the bathroom you
have no choice but to see
the strip club wow you have to see it
yeah and it was
dope see you guys are complaining man
this is the problem no one's complaining
you guys sound like you're i wish they
had a little bit of a tan but whatever
yeah yeah but you guys sound like you're
complaining man dude
protests and strip clubs that's what
portland does
i guess i would go up there to get a
little see a little yeah get yourself a
nice [ __ ] dark roast coffee
but the scary part is you get in there i
feel like into these strip clubs brendan
and you don't know a lot but
you get into places and they take
advantage of you dude that's the problem
if you're a [ __ ] cuck not with me
dude i have a whole [ __ ] plan
dude what you've never had a plan
from the strip club yeah point you can't
just come in
looking like that and expect they're not
going to
jack your pockets i look like i do lawn
care for care bears
first of all you've never had a freaking
plan dude give him you got a plan dude
you you're just going open-minded with
your [ __ ]
pockets stuffed with cash daddy look
look
i love you i'll tell you right now i'll
tell you right now you stand go to the
bathroom
you're probably gonna get money too with
them cheeks
dudes everyone's like god damn shawty
got an ass
hey that's my friend theo man bro here's
what i'm telling you is
if you didn't start popping about four
weeks going stand up you'd be stripping
son
oh my god but what i'm saying and you're
not listening is you send me videos back
dude what do you think of this dog
dude i would stick with stand up right
now like but just check this out
if you cut him off one more time i'm
trying to get so he doesn't get it out
yeah
because he doesn't have a plan that's
why he never had a plan if you read your
diary dude
which you quit writing in because it was
hard to do
you would realize that you never had a
plan okay
strip club gotta have a plan man nothing
makes me more excited than getting home
i got a box full of meat
do you oh dude a box full of real nice
meat for your mouth
oh dude i don't want any of that you do
though you don't think you do but you do
man i'm talking about butcher box oh
meat
and quality they go hand in hand baby oh
look
you talk about hidden costs with low
quality meat you know they have the the
bad flavor they just
they're not taking care of their meat
you know the meat it looks like somebody
already ate it sometimes or
it looked like the meat been through a
car wash it's not good man you know how
hard is to find 100 grass-fed
beef dude very hard how about organic
free-range
chicken what about that oh yeah a lot of
a lot of chickens you get they've been
having to work all day at the business
place work all day at the um
you know working for amazon in traffic
they're all stressed out they taste
different yeah oh they taste like they
definitely like they haven't seen their
kids all day
not that free range man luckily there's
butcher box butcher box believes that
everyone deserves high quality meat man
that's right all
of butcher box meat is free of
antibiotics
and added hormones each box has
nine to eleven two pounds of meat
almost too much meat of delicious meat
every month butcherbox ships
a curated selection of high-quality
meats right to the crib butcherbox is a
no-brainer it's the best meat
shipped right to your door which means
no more grocery
ttl baby just go to butcherbox.com
k-a-t-s and experience this meet
that's butcherbox.com
k-a-t-s butcherbox.com kats check it out
for yourself
bro you know your boy had the rona over
here yeah doctor's like man number one
thing stay hydrated
stay hydrated and this just ain't i'm
not just doing this because
this is the ad but you know i did i
loaded up on the liquid iv
man three four times a day oh wow it's
healthy
it's good man it's like drinking three
bottled waters just you put
one little freaking packet pack it in
that water
shake it up it's like drinking three to
four bottles doug oh mike do that three
four times a day
what rona beat it nerd wow
sayonara corona yes here's what i like
most about liquid iv and i do love it
is that if i go for a run a jog or if i
get scared and just
you know even hide and sweat then
i will when i finally get to the liquid
iv and i make it in the kitchen
when i drink it it tastes i can feel it
going into my body dude i like to watch
naked and afraid and they're all
dehydrated i'm sipping on that liquid iv
oh that's living brother living large
baby one
serving of liquid iv provides the same
hydration yes as he said of drinking two
to three
bottles essential vitamins more vitamin
c than an
orange that's what you need man
healthier than all those sugary sports
drinks you don't need that
no artificial flavors or preservatives
none of that less sugar than an apple
all right yep and right now we have a we
have a deal for you to try it out
liquid iv is available nationwide at
costco
and target never heard of it or you can
get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com
and use code kats at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code kats
at liquid iv.com get
better hydration today at
liquid ivy.com promo code k-a-t-s
i now i know nick's a aficiona of
[ __ ] strip club
uh you're not gonna believe it but i'm
not actually not a huge fan thank you
nick
i've actually been there but like i
don't get it i'd rather go to a bar
and uh try to do it yourself
[Laughter]
i'm not saying my batting percentage is
high i'm just saying
bro he's the bro he's the john henry and
you're the you're just that machine that
just does whatever
he shows up with that pickaxe dude you
know and my heart explodes yeah
at the end and his heart explodes so
basically that's books about slavery i
don't know if you guys know that or not
john henry the steel driving man i don't
know what the [ __ ] we're talking about i
don't know how to make a movie or
whatever what are you to
bring him up john henry let's bring him
up the steel driving mate henry the
running back for alabama
they tricked him into a bet to do all
that work basically that's dave henry
dude
the founder of wendy's that's dave
thomas
it is thomas oh my god if you know one
more white thing
[Laughter]
only chappelle would have a dave thomas
tattoo on his back
i like redheads uh now that's john henry
right there
you see him and what did he do what's he
famous for uh he
there's a folklore they had a new
machine to uh
make some tunnel i will find out which
one and he said he could tunnel it
himself
and he raced the machine and he actually
beat it but when he got there his heart
exploded
yep oh but he beat it
this is a real story or folklore yes he
is said to have worked as a
steel-driving man
see brendan classic folk song man that's
some [ __ ]
well is it that's why you get hustled in
the strip club
john henry to these [ __ ] man what's
wrong with you dude they
they like that i think a lot of those
women are looking for information
education
you know you go in there with a
community college sweatshirt on they
flock to you bro
you know a lot of guys think you got to
go into a strip club with like a you
know money and do this there he is there
he is that legend
yeah bro that is square hamburgers
dude that is chappelle and white faces
that is
we got to get you a time right i know
right
he looks warm he looks like a jehovah's
witness right after lunch that's what he
looks like as well
did he pass away yeah yeah and then
wendy runs [ __ ] now
his daughter's still alive can you get a
picture of wendy thomas and get a look
at her
oh he died a while ago yeah she's pretty
hot man yeah she does the commercials
now
she does yeah uh i don't think she does
there she is right there yeah she's the
face
i had some pictures of her right there
was a little too friendly with the
drawings
that artist was the artist blind to the
[ __ ]
what are you talking about dude you know
exactly what i'm talking about
what the [ __ ] that's what he got out of
that
there she is on the bot right there and
the young one dude i never seen no thick
ass
wendy on any billboard oh that's her oh
man
oh [ __ ] jen likes her she talks about
that she's cute
she's cute it's cute that little double
stacked pin over there
look at those two strips of bacon
hanging off the back of her neck too
dude
that's what i like you're crazy if you
don't think she invented the [ __ ]
the milkshake with the fries and yeah
the frosting
little thick ass wendy why not be real
dude i'd much prefer when to be thick
on the billboard that makes you want to
go not some little skinny girl
theo debate club wendy or jared fogle's
sister
oh that's a good call i don't know if
everybody i got a bj actually from jared
fogle's sister
wait what yeah in 2000 or sometimes get
that foot long
did you keep saying that no that foot
long you're disgusting brendan
and this is why you're struggling in
your life
jay foge bro he was different back then
it's back for all the pediatrics this is
when he was 600 pounds
no i think he was probably about 210 at
that point he was on his way down
on the way down
hey but what does his sister look like
do we have she doesn't have much of a
social media presence we couldn't find
her yeah probably laying low
would you wait hold on she doesn't have
much of a social media presence
she's on every freaking picture of a
dang wendy's across the country that's
enough
no no we're talking about the followers
followers
talking about the footlong
[Laughter]
[Music]
everything is a vague food sexual
reference when it comes to dude you're
the one that hooked up with full
sister i bro i would have nothing to do
with it i would call it
about wendy's thick ass and you talking
about football sister
i would call it dating very briefly at
night i wouldn't call it
but where did my question is where'd you
meet her that
in louisiana it wasn't a money play what
are you talking about dude
what are you talking about legit just
get the game yeah you're dressed like
the evil banker for a lesbian freaking
softball team
you need a banker help
you look like you should be in that
movie money breast
that's a movie it would be it's like
moneyball but it's about lesbians
[Laughter]
and brendan plays the evil manager the
evil financial group
stealing money leaking the money who's
being shady and doing nasty stuff
and walking to the bathroom of a mexican
restaurant and going and looking at
titties and stuff y'all
yeah it's called a plan yeah you had a
plan with fogel's sister dude you tell
brendan two ideas that are gonna happen
in the same day and he's like that's
insane
like that's a plan you delinquent chin
you've been this i feel like chin would
be a little stiff at the strip
no don't use chin as a get out of jail
free card every time we rip into brendan
dude he's like hey [ __ ]
what are you doing dude you chased that
big titty girl away from the freaking uh
well i was worried how many times are
you gonna beat this [ __ ] dead horse
on the plant thing
bro this whole show is beating a dead
horse
yeah that's your nickname dead horse
what is this uh just some cats in the
wild uh someone saw theo on the train
i'm like oh [ __ ] that looks like just me
just snacking stam that's so good
snackies
snacky
where was i going huh probably somewhere
that i'd written down earlier in the day
in a planet
yeah you're even looking at your watch
it looks like yeah yeah busy
what is she snacking on there that ain't
a woman you
[ __ ]
actually she has that starting pitcher
for the reds
for the marlborough reds that lady ain't
a
[Laughter]
if that's a lady then i'm a lady yeah
so i've been trying to tell you this
whole time bro that's me
where was i going probably chasing that
honey over there in a white
shirt yeah that little lady with that
lean head bruh
a lot of lean-headed women out there
a little skinny head there huh a lot of
lean-headed women right there
that looks like me right now yeah oh now
or i mean whenever but definitely like
me now
wow and then we've got uh chappelle
uh useless in the wild
he was a little bit in his feelings
i'm always in my feelings yeah i respect
it yeah have you met
this guy his feelings are great there
you go
get that shirt feelings are great yeah
it is now oh fillings are great dude you
could be a colonel in the antifa
military dude if you got a feelings or
great shirt
oh seems pretty far
[Music]
delilah i can promise you that by the
[Music]
time
because he's in secret dude he's in an
adoption home
he's have to be secret yeah it wasn't
bad though was it it wasn't
it wasn't and here you are now
bill see that's when you were that's
when that's when yeah that's what i was
on
uh you know what did they call it you
were looking for us whatever it was
before the back flip
do you like them who is that do i like
playing white no i don't like that man
nobody would have guessed that no i
don't like that that's a little too
emotional for me well two emo little to
emo
yeah i was never part of the emo phase
what
yeah were you but there there's but we
don't have
tons of proof that i was or was it
everything you talk you're a freaking
living hallmark card aisle
you are the emo face dude
who who who's the king of em like emo
raps big right who's the king of emo rap
kids kid cudi would be emotional maybe a
little
backpack rappers yeah they get all sad
and
start rapping yeah cuddy's got some
pretty sad songs honestly we may have
done this on the show where i just saw
it on social media a couple times but uh
theo
and brandon were in a movie a while ago
that no one ever talks about for some
reason
this is from just watch this
tremors great movie jamie kennedy's in
there amy
no that's a great dune he was in dune
oh that does look like they look like
much better
hollywood versions of us who's that on
the right
what's his name handsome i don't know
his name it is
clive owen no no no no he's older this
guy's real oh
tremors are great movie is this fred
ward
freddy ward huh there's a cr there's a i
think he's korean don't get mad at me i
think
there's a korean guy in that movie too
in tremors he dies yeah
oh the kid right nope nope he's the old
man all the old old dudes yeah
he's japanese is he japanese is he
japanese i thought he was korean he's
also
in uh big trouble in china victor wong
so that's chinese
dude i'm just pissed you guys brought
these donuts man you don't like them i
didn't want to eat today
i come in i figured everybody got up
early i'd be nice and bring people
donuts and you come in like a
[ __ ] won't you bring people a salad
why don't you bring
people something good for them a little
bit of steroids bruh
bring that off for everybody just
little ass shots dude one time i was
partying somewhere
i think in new york or something a buddy
of mine
uh he's like hey man i'm going to get
some drugs right it's probably like
1am or 2 a.m and
i was like ah all right man whatever
he's like come with me i was like nah
man i'm chilling man i'm going to sleep
man it was pretty late yeah i'm not
believing this
you're not no you probably got the drugs
well here's what happened
i would have i said wake me up when you
get back with the drugs smart
you know what i'm saying respect you got
a plan yeah dude thank you bro
yeah had a little bit of a plan right um
so the guy comes back he is freaking
steroid to the drugs he bought
it's 4 30 in the morning he's trying to
party
he had a plan to get in shape bro well
look but i'm like dude it takes two
weeks for those to kick in he's not
whatever and he just shot him up right
there into his butt
and did he get swole huh i don't know i
went back to sleep but i saw him
oh my goodness one of his eyes turned a
different color
you got that bootleg new york he got
that bootleg [ __ ] not the [ __ ] a-rod was
taking
dude i yeah i bought some bootleg stuff
off of a dude one time
and it was bootleg steroids oh yeah
real regional type stuff you know easy
to boot like steroids
yeah because you could just put olive
oil into a thing yeah then just blame it
on you got shitty genetics
yeah it's not my fault it's not working
yeah yeah look at your dad's wrists
[Laughter]
yeah you guys just don't have it
you just don't have that for everybody
man yeah here's another couple ounces
man it's extra virgin
shoot it into your butt cheek meanwhile
your butt cheeks rotting off your body
but here's a guy right here who's got
some strong information
you can tell out of the blue because it
is whatever time year it is right now
which is i think summer
and there is a christmas tree he's too
lazy to take in the background
yeah and now he's already past that uh
that center that middle
yeah you might as well leave it up yeah
yeah
theo what's up got a king it for you
gang brother
got that billy conforto shirt on r.i.p
uh king understing it
colonoscopies uh myself i have
ulcerative colitis which is an irritable
bowel disease so i've had like seven
colonoscopies in my life
wow they're not too bad you know they
slide you some drugs
uh you pass out they're all up in your
holes
uh i like to refer to it as that bill
colinas cosby
get what i'm saying um just want to say
i love you guys
i've been sick actually with this
disease the last couple years uh i've
been restricted to being at home a lot
uh your podcast really helps keeps my
spirits up
everybody down there at the king and
sting fam you guys are making me laugh
every week uh or if i'm real sad i'll
pull like a
theo and listen to some bishop gun turn
on some shine or
i'll pull up brendan and like just get
punched in the head and forget
stuff like this amen bro love you guys
hope you come through st
louis soon uh gang gang swollen colon
nick is that different than what your
sister does oh yeah
uh colonoscopy they just stick a camera
up there my sister washes it out
oh wow
look that's that andy do frame what his
sister does
they should have a special package
called that andy dufresne
you know yeah where they washed two
dudes out of your butt in and out
they said it would take 600 years this
is my morgan freeman impersonation and
i'll do it for you guys because
half you guys are pieces of [ __ ]
it's your only brendan impression
you can't let me do it all right i've
heard it though
they said it would take a minute 600
years to get out of the sea of prison
but andy dufresne did it in less than
20.
that's him crawling through some [ __ ]
pretty good huh
i actually got to give you props on that
one thank you man i appreciate that
uh yeah that's a tough time bro this is
a tough time and this before they had
the camera they would send a guy in
there right there that's that video
um yeah thanks for the shout out man and
yeah i think put all the christmas trees
up man if you got to keep your spirits
up
yeah if that makes you happy leave them
up dog yeah do put up a halloween you
know
go door to door and ask for candy do
whatever you got to do man
cake all day doug yeah uh
what was this guy asking about i can't
understand
i'll take one i'm not doing two though
if you wanna
check it out i guess i'll do it you know
but here
brendan's the kind of guy that would get
a colonoscopy by laying on his back and
holding his legs open
like a baby i would do it on my back and
you do it on all fours
dude all fours is the way to do it bro i
don't think so dude what
i think i think you're passed out right
and they just flip you over
dude well i'm passing out on all fours
dawg you know what i'm saying like a
champion
yeah dude like a baby with his butt in
there why'd he leave a thong on
dude i think you got to go if i'm going
colonoscopy
i guess man i mean if you need them do
it dog
are they good to do huh they say they
are but they say a lot of stuff man it's
basically
vaccine for your butt so if you want to
you know
if you're i'm more of an anti-vaxxer i
think
i think you know i haven't read up on it
but it seems fun dude
how do you know if you need one though
you know if you feel like it
does your butt feel kind of risky i
don't know if it's much of the butt more
so the
the hole you ever had a hemorrhoid no
have you had one
i think i did have one yeah that's
that's enough you've had one oh yeah
wow how'd you get it
lifting heavy weights and being
overweight
you can get it just from being
overweight oh wow if you're overweight
and you lift real heavy weight like
there's a lot of strain like i was
dead lifted or squatting in college i
just remember my
[ __ ] itch like never before and i
keep itching it and just got worse worse
and worse
and the next thing you know you got this
grape size
hemorrhoids it was awful
you're disgusting dude that's life bruh
that ain't life dude
i've been alive and that's not happened
to him and then some people have they
have to tie it off with a rubber band
and surgically remove them no
first of all the person that just puts
cream on it is a pervert
okay that's what you gotta do dude if
something's hanging out of my buttocks
and i'm putting cream on it i know i'm a
freak bro you're a freak huh
second of all yeah you gotta cut that
thing off dude i'd have a couple beers
and cut that [ __ ] off
you know set up a couple of mirrors in
your room to be able to do it and
you know in it you know was it bad to
use the restroom
awful ah nick you've never had a
hemorrhoid
out of anybody
i don't know dude i had appendicitis
once and before they found it they stuck
their fingers up my butt it wasn't a
full colonoscopy but
that felt weird yeah yeah no hemorrhoids
though i don't even know if you needed
to tell us that story oh yeah yeah i had
nothing to do with hamburglar
just trying to yes and no you're right
that's a good call you're right you're
right you're right good
good job it's good you're not into the
ass play well here's the thing man
is if you have i think i don't know if i
where i'm from i think if you have bad
shrimp you can get them you know that's
fair
so it's more of what your diet is
a lot of pregnant girls get them really
yeah yeah because when they're pushing
the baby then the hemorrhoids go oh my
god have the
struggle yeah the strain oh my god
that's not fun
man you need help man you need better
help i don't know who you're going to
for help but you need to get some better
help
and it's easy man better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
i've used it
on your phone yeah you can do it dude in
under 48 hours you start talking to
these
experts all right i've used it man it's
available worldwide oh i pulled over i
had to go to a damn uh
like a quinceanera you know or whatever
the year after that is you know
16 watcher yeah yeah
and so i and i got nervous on the way
there
next thing you know i'm on the phone
with my therapist dude through better
help
right there sometimes you can facetime
sometimes it can be a call
there's just ways you can get someone to
talk to if there's not someone in your
area
or if maybe going to like a you know you
don't want to drive down there and go to
that building or
maybe you're embarrassed see you walk in
and say oh you're going to see the
special person yeah quit talking to your
friend all the time maybe your friend
doesn't have all the answers yeah maybe
your friend's a dumbass
get with a licensed professional right
now it's more affordable
than traditional uh counseling right
financial aid is also available better
help wants you to start living a happier
life
right now visit their website read their
testimonials they are
posted daily go to betterhelp.com
kats that's better h-e-l-p and joined
over
1 million people taking charge of their
mental health
right now with experienced professionals
all right special offer for you guys
king of sting listeners you get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s yeah we know it's a tough time
and everybody needs some help sometimes
especially if you listen to this show
you probably need help you need a lot of
help so get it betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
damn what's this sunburnt fella saying
this show just breaks my heart man
up brandon what up yeah i'm trevor from
east texas got a quick king of yours
hold on pause it real quick this is
actually
your picture huh this guy looks like
he's in nasa but they don't wear any
helmets dude this guy
has some sunburn
just space east texas got a quick kinder
sing it for you
uh getting your picture with somebody
that you consider a superstar
if you see them out in public and
they're not like going to the bathroom
or eating with their family or anything
do you get a picture with them or do you
just respect their space and leave them
alone
from your point of view what what do you
think also
while i got you here i'm trying to get
it quick rip my drip brennan
waited three weeks for this bad boy i
know you see me filling out this double
xl
oh damn oh
anyway it's a huge fan of the show doing
what you do in game buzz buzz
gang bro that dude will meet you at 270
man
yeah 260. straight up that guy's big man
that's a double x oh you could slaughter
that guy you know and sell his meat
it's a big ass nasa employee oh i'd have
a you know i'd have a couple pounds of
that guy what's his name victor
it was uh i thought it was tyler
yeah i think tyler who who's the last
picture you gotta
who's the last celebrity you gotta pick
with i say leave them alone
well here's what you do if you're a boss
boy in tucson arizona
in uh the late 90s you bring as much
unordered food as you can to their table
if it's kevin costner
that's what i did that's what you did
yeah you go i love water world man i
don't give a [ __ ] what they say water
wasn't out yet
in the 90s yeah brendan what'd you say
to him huh
what'd you say to him i just brought a
bunch of bread and rolls over there
was he cool but he's like what am i
gonna do with all this like they had to
stop me they gave me a break at work
they and we never had breaks there
wasn't breaks
hey theo want to take a break once you
leave kevin for a little bit
in the 90s he was a huge star oh he was
dude he was a legend yeah and him
and the guy from fresh prince of bel air
came in the young fella not will smith
alfonso riviero yeah he came in
he's great people were fired up carlton
he's the host of uh
america's uh what is that the game show
yeah which one you took over for bob
saget oh america's
funny videos yeah oh good for him yeah
um
[Music]
i did a golf tournament with me too
isn't that weird
nice guy where'd you do it at in florida
oh that would kind of be a fun segment
if people send in like legit
old school home videos that were taking
on like a
a camera or something from when their
childhood our own version
or people send this picture of them with
celebrities that's that too
there's that i like them both i like
them both
i love home movies like the old school
ones like when you're just someone's
following around to family
oh yeah christmas or something nothing
happens i don't know
they always show a little bit of that on
like murder shows and stuff yeah that's
awesome
sounds like nick has a plan yeah alan
grew up in a good home it says yeah
they show him like running with a gift
nick you've been hanging out with chin
too much
i was just going to say it's gone now
but do you have the picture of you with
your new axe
chin oh you got a new axe what to kill
them little fish
yeah i thought it was an axe but
everyone's calling it a hatchet i guess
when it's a smaller version of an axe
axe or longer probably a hatchet maybe
you read my side of the mountain
what depend what part of uh town you're
in some people might call it a tomahawk
possibly tomahawk too
that porter house that tomahawk that
time
it's an east wing isn't hatching a book
can you air drop me yeah
yeah it is a book yeah that's the book
i'm talking about hatches
that's what yeah i was like wait there
you go and why the [ __ ] you get it chin
you know i'm going camping recently so
to chop up some firewood hey man brother
hey
oh you're going camping friday i hatch
it thursday and friday
match it's a good book here's chin right
here with that hat did you post that
video open up like it's a box of [ __ ]
jays or something it's one of the it was
it was a really good surprise
oh you think you'd previously open this
supposed to come in a week later
yeah yeah you open it went all right
let's run this back get your camera out
it finally came in oh see i'm happy
it's a week early it's a nice it's a
very nice hatchet thank you that is a
nice [ __ ] app
and what do you what are you going to do
with that chop wood
sound like a murderer bro you sound like
some of this kind of there's a hatchet
book yeah
yeah it won that silver medal thing this
is a book brennan it's a
did your mom read it to you or whatever
no i'm trying to describe everything
in school yeah it's like if somebody
took a piece of paper a bunch of little
stacks of paper
and put it like a like a story in it
it's like a stack of them that's cool do
you have your degree controls
i might agree on my phone i think dude
imagine getting a college degree right
now like
what are you gonna do with it yeah yeah
yeah what are you gonna do with this i
don't know what the [ __ ] you to do with
it
i don't know where mine's at i don't
know did you get your degree in again
uh business and sociology oh wow smart
guy huh
wow yeah yeah what did you major in
uh cheerleading
damn about anything else yeah i feel
damn bro she's killing the cheer game
damn that's all you can do dog yeah
defense bro yeah defense
you know shoot the two shoot the two
what else you got nick
damn chin you were oh oh here comes
cat's ex-boyfriend
straight out of kuala lumpur prison
sorry we just had to include cat cat
hasn't said anything the entire time
it is early i'll give you that it's
early it ain't that early or not yeah
it's pretty early
hey it's pretty early cat do you know
anyone that looks like this guy or not i
know three people who looks exactly like
him
yeah i love this guy i love this guy too
he seems like a nice
guy i got the big club also a koala bear
brendan whose comedy camp would you
rather be in
gang gang buzz buzz you started over
please nick brendan was interrupting
everything
hey guys i got the big club adam sandler
or seth rogen
who's comedy camp would you rather be in
gang gang buzz buzz seems like a nice
fella
yeah wait wait did we do this before not
the crew there he's kind of taking like
like the crew
the rat pack like i'm going sandler i
think
i love sandlin yeah they're a little
older though
you know like the whole crew's a little
older yeah
at least seth rogen they're more of our
age yeah seth roger yeah
but like spades you know spade's super
close
sandlin you're close with spades spade's
about yeah he's probably 50.
they're all they're all they all they're
all getting older that's true
who who south brogan it's like what it's
him who else
um oh james jonah hill
yeah i don't know if that's his crew
though that's jonah hillis
him and jonah hillary and james franco
yeah that's the crew and then the
homeboy in the back is our friend too
the canadian kid
jay beerushall yeah look at farley look
at that picture if you go nick
down right right there look how big
farley was
god damn damn look how big he was can we
go back to that next
man that's crazy i've never seen him
that big
it's just the angle i don't think it is
though you can see look how his hand is
and that was
everything pretty fast yeah look at that
he's got the real
uh fat bastard double chin going on yeah
that's tough wow r.i.p
and chris rock just skinny as [ __ ] and
still skinny as [ __ ] yeah yeah
um i'm gonna go it's such a tough
question i'm gonna stay out of both of
them adam sandler's crew's got way more
money for sure
i'd rather be in my crew yeah our crew
is pretty cool
obviously not successful but different
you know
like they're they're older man i'm not
going to really fit in with a bunch of
50 year olds
well well brian yeah
you're 47. yeah i'm 46.
you might fit him perfectly yeah yeah
maybe yeah you might be that young
little
that young little buddy the little that
little thotty dog thick twink
are you 37 right yeah but you're gonna
age man
yeah it's coming nothing you do try that
donut dog tell me what you think of it
like a fried wine you're gonna age
why do you have your doughnut like that
huh what are you doing
i don't like having it just in big
pieces like that
i like getting more of like a lozenge
just
almost like a suppository dude when i
was young you used to have suppositories
remember that
yeah get your vitamins through your butt
praise god man
poof it yeah boof it dude what else you
got nick
we didn't answer we didn't answer
anybody well we both said we'd rather
not be in it
we gotta just stick with our crew
here's brennan's son that he won't admit
about
my amish son this one's a little long
but yo what's up king and the sting gang
new listener here
how's this [ __ ] [ __ ] sure during the
content just got done with some
brazilian jiu jitsu
ain't nothing better than the feeling of
a full-grown man on top of you choking
you out brandon theo i'm sure you know
what i'm talking about boys
um chen lay low bro i know you didn't do
anything to that glee lady i know it
wasn't you dude don't worry about it
um cat keep your [ __ ] socks and shoes
on around those animals because those
guys see toe knuckle hair
and they just start acting on instinct
breathing all heavy and [ __ ] who
knows what they're going to do
uh lacey the barbecue bro i want to try
that [ __ ] i'm out here in denver i can't
find any good places
uh for good barbecue that's like subpar
or whatever others
so let me know if you've got any
recommendations uh so i just watched the
episode
about um the asian food challenge [ __ ]
was hilarious
um so my debate topic today is most
attractive asian person
my vote is for korean i don't know why
like i just think their facial structure
like they were bred to be models i don't
know dude
i mean they're coming from a subpar
average looking dude like i just see
koreans and i'm like whoa what the [ __ ]
like why they look like they were
sculpted at a marble
sure but uh enjoy the content everyone
stays i think he's hitting on chin
yeah maybe what happens that was true i
thought he was going to give us a
specific example of the hottest asian
yeah yeah but he went
type of asian what do you say cat cause
being asian is it harder
to embrace the visuality you know what
comes into your eyes of of other asians
i do think that being asian i can
differentiate different asians better
than like brendan kind of
picks up on the different asians but
aaron
you're definitely getting better but
first i just refer to everybody as
asian yeah yeah that's good though
uh i think for me i think filipino girls
are
the hottest girls and then for guys
i want to say
yeah i'm going to go filipinos if you're
into short guys if you're into taller
guys koreans
oh yeah so koreans let's just say
koreans to make it
korean koreans all the way around yeah
no one likes shortcuts
yeah filipino men uh
a lot of them work at like uh senior
care centers as well senior care
centers they're nurses loving jobs they
work in the post office
oh really yeah a lot of uh filipino post
office workers
wow i didn't know he talked about it he
does i love that i didn't know that i
feel much better mailing something yeah
i really do knowing that some filipinos
are going to handle it
because those people are usually really
nice people
i assume he only exclusively exclusively
dates asians
he gives me that vibe or at least he
tries to yeah he definitely hunts him
online yeah
who this is jokoy yes
[Laughter]
manny over here still working for post
office
i just want to let you know that i saw
your netflix special my god
spectacular i mean what a show
if that comedian stuff doesn't work for
you
your uncle manny has a job
you know there's one thing that's
bothering me huh i still haven't
received my uh
t-shirt
[Laughter]
we're raining around show all my friends
huh you'll owe me one of those
maybe you forgot your uncle manny's
address
don't address this if you're going to be
at the post office huh
hey all right i gotta go i love you
i'll help you
uncle manny love joe a lot of filipinos
have the name manny as well you know
yeah a lot of manny
a lot of spanish last names too hmm i
like that joko i made it a merch
commercial
and a commercial for his netflix special
he got so funny he got them both in
there
yeah he's a killer he's one of my
favorite people
you're friends with him yeah yeah yeah i
would love to meet that yeah open for
jokoy
you did wow the nicest guy
yeah oh yeah the nicest guy gives
everyone a joe what up man
you don't oh you don't know joe oh
you're just a fan
yeah he's [ __ ] great do you start
living yeah
he's in vegas he's living in vegas yeah
yeah he lives in base
he does yeah wow sends me videos to him
on atvs and [ __ ]
that's fun and he was like oh is la shut
down still i'm like
well yeah dude he's like i've just been
out here in the desert
this big-ass lot wow shooting some music
video this week you want to talk about a
hustler
do you hear how he got on netflix do you
ever hear the story how you got on
netflix
they kept turning they wouldn't do it
they went taking he's like this that
time when netflix was just starting to
pop
he's like well i got to be on there like
all the big communes are on there
netflix like we're good man
so he shot it high production shot it
put all his money into it
and was like netflix take it you can
have it for free oh that first one that
one he did in washington where he blew
up
and he blew up yeah and then he has a
show now on netflix too where he goes
the philippines
yeah yeah he has like a bunch of [ __ ] on
netflix
but they were like nope nope then he
filmed it all himself and was like you
just have for free if you just put it on
yeah they didn't blew up okay you know
what that boy sells
like what 18 shows at brea 18 shows
sold out the forum i mean he sells out
hawaii like a [ __ ] unreal but he
sold out where the [ __ ] warriors
played that giant arena oh the
he does he's a local yeah or uh twice
he's an arena play now damn wow monster
and the nicest guy in the world well
and i'm still doing this shitty show
here
what's this guy's problem we've just
been kind of instigating beef with all
these uh delivery men what's up bros i
was listening to your debate
about the next ups i was a little hurt
because you left someone out talking
about that og
street creep boy amen
what's up man i'm fighting any of those
[ __ ]
he has the same glasses off the kid off
family or as a family or
the yeah family guy with the killer
family that has those exact same glasses
well american dad
millions of people what's his name
american dad is that the kid yeah you
right american dessert
steve right oh man yeah they're the
exact millions of people have those
glasses
i don't think so dude not those okay
good call actually
i'm going
uh i'm gonna go out on a short limb and
say that this guy
looks like um american uh
that guy that's the killer that kills
the people
making a murderer go american psycho god
do you think he looks like christian
bale
at this angle yeah you start drinking
this morning huh no you freaking
lacy with all these donuts you know what
sugar is alcohol brendan
it's unfermented alcohol
that's such a tough reference
he looks like christian bail bondsmen
oh man i got to get a new sponsor man
what else is going on
[Laughter]
wait did we even answer what the best
looking asian is we didn't even answer
brendan
oh yeah korean dude i know did we yeah
no i said it but
chappelle what do you think um i think
it's case by case
well let's tell talk brendan yeah let
him talk dude
he's gonna die of arteriosclerosis from
running a bunch of hamburger joints
any month now
um the hottest asians
are probably thai oh
that's a good one let's bring it bring
up some thai
that's a great call wow you surprised me
with that that's a great call
pull up a bunch of tie neck oh jack talk
tai
i want to see uh some thai let's see
what we got here
also probably the best food out of the
asian culture let's go to that one with
us
there we go let's see what's up here
okay now here's thigh right here
and the beautiful thing about this is
you don't know if they're women or men
yep
wow the lady boys out there trick you
ryan callum got tricked didn't realize
it he grabbed a whole handful full of
nuts
and then he didn't want to disrespect
the
whatever the the man so he just kept
going don't kiss him
really yeah really you don't want to
hurt his feelings i respect that
right i mean i don't like i wouldn't do
it probably if i could but you can see
yeah
but i think good guy very respectful of
different cultures
yeah he's a good guy well yeah because
he can't tell out there
yeah and look the the wild thing is is
they don't really have a lot of hips so
you don't really know that hips is in a
giveaway
that crot that whole hip hip booty area
it's all very vague around there i think
you want to be suspicious of any of them
that cover up their wrists
that's a kind of a big tell you how do
you
know this sounds like you've had some
experience
i've i've heard pray tell and like
seeing them across the room and they'll
have gloves on or something
at a club have you been there huh
i was at a packer bar in santa monica
it's called uh
mom moz or something okay and uh there
was a girl sitting by herself she was
all decked out in packer gear
we were talking to her she was from
germany she loved the packers she was
drinking beer
we were like talking to each other and
we exchanged numbers and one of my
buddies when she left she was
he was like that was a dude and then
so i i was already i was like honestly
actually you might be right now that i
think about it but i was just kind of
texting
kind of get more info and i was like
because we had made plans for saturday
yeah i was like so what are you doing
what are you doing tomorrow and she's
like uh i thought it was going to hit up
the abbey
and i was like all right i'm out because
abby is uh
the gay boy but a lot a lot of straight
women go there too
yeah not by themselves when they're
overseas from germany i don't think
maybe you never know
dude either way i'm not a risk i'm
willing to take
come on nick i live a little dude
well here's the thing when i was really
a child if somebody else if you liked
women and somebody had a wiener
it was really more taboo you know sure
now it's not as wild because people
getting their wieners taken off
titty put on you know somebody put a
titty where their wiener was you know
they got people out there pissing out of
a d cup you know
this is a different ball game now but
i'm going to say what is the best
looking asian brennan you have to answer
and you can't just piggyback off of
these good people's answers
listen i think it's case by case you
know what's awesome is she japanese
it's case by case yes probably i i guess
japanese i'll go different
japanese but usually korean what like
the korean pop stars are pretty small
but then they do have surgery so it's
kind of a toss-up you know
what about a lot of work one girl from
charlie's angels lucy lou
lucy lou chinese they're all they're all
they're all a bunch of pretty girls that
are asian but you know a lot of
beautiful women
yeah yeah even though i'm korean i've
only pretty much dated vietnamese i
think vietnamese girls are
same the cutest yeah oh yeah both of you
guys are dating vietnamese girls
then i'm gonna go to vietnam
you bet hey nick have you exclusive
you've only dated asian women
is that your type or this is just no
it's my first i was
uh this is the longest i've ever dated a
degree girl uh yeah
don't hurt him daddy uncle tom
bro black girls
they say yeah i said uncle tom stabbing
there's a lot of girls
i think i'm blushing wow
the cheese head with a beard
[Laughter]
that dark queso bro
that's cinnamon queso baby nick you
didn't have any clue that
you were talking to a man setting up a
date on saturday with a man
nothing set off red flags the german
accent
i think hid a lot of it and she was she
was uh asian
no she's white a white oh dude your
buddy might have lied to you because i
feel like that's how i like
yeah that's that would be easier to know
i'm picturing an
asian person in a packers gear from
germany yeah
and that would be a little you're like i
don't know yeah there's a little bit of
commentary dude with a cheese hat on
and you thought it was a chick do you
mess with
me am i just being gay that day send up
plans
no i think it was a chick nick it sounds
like it was a chick it's a german chick
is almost a man
missed opportunity but now i met my
girlfriend so everything works out
[Laughter]
except my girlfriend didn't even know
who brett favre was which is kind of
until he was treading on twitter because
he gulf of donald trump
oh people are pissed at me but we'll
close out with a king
sink my ink did you hold on did you guys
see the donald trump uh
bar stool interview thing do you see
that clip yet that's all like a little
part of it
will you play that up next i want to see
it real quick boys interviewing the
president of the united states
and he's talking about how he used to be
in rap videos and stuff it makes him
more human
you know wait to see this clip this is
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen
which clip are we looking for uh portnoy
interviews trump they'll end the
interview
did you notice that he stuck his hand
out and said what do i do here
rather than insult him i said fine i
appreciate that
hey i immediately ran washington you
just
heard of dave in the days from
like four months ago yeah i just you
know i i
people don't know that i get along
really great with the world leaders i'm
tougher with the world leaders
go forward a little next i just want to
see if you talk about the twitter thing
sorry i'm slowing everything down no
it's all good he taught
so they're in the relationship he asked
him specifically dan how many what's our
number yeah here we go
can you believe it what happens to this
twitter account is it yours when it's
over
it looks like it's mine and i don't know
if i'll ever use it again but
it certainly uh was good it's a platform
look we have fake news you don't know
about that but we have fake news out
there i
very much know about that that exists in
my world as well and then you know dave
that
uh we we have a we have a voice we have
a very big voice when you have the kind
of numbers
that we have uh you're able to get the
word out in an honest word and it's
important so it's been
very important for me do you sometimes
because you're i follow you on twitter
and i know i do this but my
i'm not the pres well my nickname is el
prez but it's true i'm a company so
we're doing it
do you ever tweet out and be like wake
up oh man i wish i didn't send that one
out often too often
you put it on your desk and then you go
back tomorrow and you say oh i'm glad i
didn't send it right
but we don't do that with twitter we
we put it out instantaneously we feel
great
and then you start getting phone calls
did you really say this i said what's
wrong with that
and you find a lot of things you know
what i find it's not the tweets it's the
retweets that get you in trouble
you've been taught and retweeted people
like oh you just retweeted this crazy
person tells you you don't even look you
just press
retweet this fire from the hip you see
something that looks good
and you don't investigate the helmet
exactly right which is a miniature
and you don't blow it up and sometimes
it's but i i have found
almost almost always it's the retweets
that get you drunk
i've seen that it makes me like it more
you got makes me like a more today
that's good so uh probably so
interesting dude i'm proud of you
you know you don't look at the links you
know you don't really look at
it you just say like oh [ __ ] it's so
ridiculous
it's so relatable though oh yeah i mean
it's just everybody
it's just so funny to think yeah that
the president's just sitting there at
night he's like oh i'ma fire this off
you know you don't want him to run his
own [ __ ] but he does and then the steam
wakes up next morning like damn
dude you retweet some [ __ ] man
it's hilarious chappelle doesn't know
who it is still that interview
is the first guy he did uh i'll tell you
who it is david portnoy is a man he's
like a pizza taste tester
and he has a bad attitude but he kind of
plays it off
and he was in a sex crime video also i
think briefly
yeah he's an entrepreneur okay i would
say that right
i'll tell you i'd say he's a business
owner and an entertainer
okay i would say he is a name game what
is dave portnoy
that's a great game what is dave portnoy
i would say he is a entrepreneur
businessman
entertainer yeah yeah east coast wreck
on tour yeah it's easy brilliant dude
he's smart dude yeah he got a he he got
a great crew a lot of those guys that
work over there with him are awesome oh
yeah i love kfc
and big cat they're all good people oh
dude they're all yeah i love all those
guys pf is the funniest guy i think on
the planet
most most underrated oh my gosh they
have two guys
can i play a a minute clip from these
guys
sure sure the uh lights camera pod it's
grease week
these two
really because it's the start of greece
week greece week that's right
um helping us this week will be our
newest producer
daniel hackbarth out of vero beach
florida danny why don't you uh pop up
and say hello
welcome to the team dan we're really
happy to have him and so
uh just like greece weeks in the past
we're gonna start this off
with the grease draft um but before we
do that
let's have a word from our sponsors
today's episode is brought to you by
fart sound effect
number seven
big thanks to those guys they've been
just a huge help to us sponsoring the
program
and we've been using them long before we
started doing this
yeah yeah and it goes on but these guys
are like the driest sense of humor and
they go on to draft the best greece
movies and there's only grease one and
grease two
oh wow that's funny it just shows you
where
nick since the humor i was waiting for
yeah just to each its own to each its
own
unbelievable it's a little it's like
yeah very dry but they're good
all right nick went from me staring at
the screen to a swipe
left we're just trying to bring this to
a screeching halt this episode for the
interview
you did a good job let's play that one
last lady and we'll end on that
yeah a lot of beautiful asians out there
though man
and i think there might be unknown
nations we don't even know about
cultures you know
oh absolutely we're hiding somewhere i
don't know where but we're hiding
but if there's any culture that could be
unknown it could easily be asian out
there in them
you know hills mountains in the hills
mountains
i could see that hey theo we saw you in
august
in atlanta brandon we were supposed to
see you in march for my birthday but
that obviously didn't happen i was
originally gonna send this video
um because you guys were talking about
oj and his money
and i was gonna tell you that uh years
ago
he set up what's called a rabbi trust
and he gets about 25
000 a month from it and nobody including
the goldmans can
touch that money uh but i figured while
i was at it i would give you a little
sink my ink
um i got this in someone's basement
it was supposed to be a winking hello
kitty
and i'm 35 and now it's just a huge
embarrassment yeah that hello kitty
looks
drunk dang she kind of reminds me of
maggie q
yeah she does maggie q the half asian
half white girl that you like in that
scary movie oh i love her
yeah now man or woman here nick do you
think i think this is a woman
that's a lady she's a very nice trying
to see where you're at you know nick
yeah we just want to start to gauge you
we're going to eat we're going to ease
you in easily
yeah that was a toss-up wow
but if you are a man pretending to be a
woman and looking to dupe some young men
apparently
wisconsin is the state together
um she does look like a beautiful young
lady
i mean she's gorgeous too bad she has a
family and stuff you know
white husband and kids oh she does huh i
don't know i'm just guessing and just
yeah probably though she's shooting him
yeah
um she looks like who maggie young the
girl on the left
that's the actress on the left she's in
some scary movies
oh oh super attractive um both of them
are
but that's instrument uh oj i wonder how
he was able to get that
rabbi trust me rabbi trump some
attorneys
yeah some attorney said it was always
wondering how he's always golfing all
the [ __ ] time
he gets how much a month 25 grand a
month
would you guys have him as a guest on t
fatca i would yep
would you i think so
we talked to uh amanda knox yeah
both killed people was amanda knox uh
she was
a killer killer yeah murder nice girl
yeah sure and she's not really a killer
either
i mean i don't think she did it she is
but you know the header on the show so
she's like a wren fair she does like
renaissance fairs oh okay
look at see that what he's into it do
you know what amanda knox is no do you
renaissance fairs oh yeah
unbelievable dude oh
didn't know barstool sports dave portnoy
it's so weird the stuff he knows yeah i
make chappelle chappelle though you know
that's why that's why you love them man
yep that's amanda right there
uh and she's rent uh
getting in some ren fair attire oh okay
that's what she likes to do
um that big ass turkey leg oh yeah now
here's a bunch of documentaries on her
you can look her up dude but now here's
the thing that i don't or you can just
watch an episode of this past
episode 225 look how excited i was i
know right
i was fired up they fell in love oh they
did
oh yeah she has a husband though she has
a husband
it might not be a true marriage i don't
know yeah it could be untrue i mean it
was
yeah i don't know where i'm sure she can
figure out how to get out of that
yeah well it's almost time for me to
have a diet coke guys so
wrapping up with some diet coke snake's
like get us out of here
we might want to wrap this up oh do we
have any announcements to make nick next
week we're talking about uh
uh british stuff don't send in
submissions but it's just something to
look forward to we've already got the
show wrapped up but it's
who can't wait i can't wait hopefully we
talk about oasis
and what about patreon we have to
announce i don't know uh yeah and uh
patreon will be launching next
thursday the same time the episode drops
you can go to the patreon and
we're going to have a bonus episode
there it's all the wraps you haven't
heard
with little brows in the culture corner
and what can they expect every month on
that patreon
hit them with it pretend you're talking
to a dude at a green bay packers
change a number yeah hit him with that
dirt knowledge
so we're gonna give you an extra episode
every month yeah it talks like you're
talking into a white
german cat brother huh it'd be like if
they added a
17th regular season game but you had to
pay for it uh
and then every episode will be available
for 360.
there'll be merch offers uh you get to
vote on the next merch products
uh we got a lot of stuff there episodes
without ads
uh visit patreon.com oh yeah that uh
addless episodes
so patreon.com it's the assless chaps of
podcasting
yeah there's addless episodes manchester
city
you can get bonus you get a bonus
episode every month you get
this podcast without ads and then you
can also get bonus footage
the 360 cam uh exclusive merch
it's gonna be dope patreon.com king in
the stink
boom oh man
brendan and theo fighter and wait i
gotta go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino every song i hit
like the great bambino burning ain't the
queso in the case of ritos but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick
[Music]
on a string